now for the main event uh the breakup of
the United States into different regions
is a workable option likely to bring a
market Improvement in human Affairs
speaking for the affirmative Professor
Frank Buckley Frank please come to the
stage
speaking for the negative uh it will be
a Libertarian party classical liberal
caucus chair Jonathan Casey Jonathan
please come to the stage
foreign
Jane please close the voting uh
Frank you have five minutes just a 15
minutes rather to speak for the
resolution there will be someone in
front flashing time cards that will warn
you five minutes two minutes and one
minute left Take it Away Frank
howdy thank you so much for having me
and a big thank you to reason Foundation
I got kind of mentored in politics by
David Knott the chairman of reasons so
I'm I'm delighted to be here to see
people like Nick now I'm asked to defend
the proposition that the breakup of the
United States in the different regions
is a workable solution likely to bring a
marked improvement in human Affairs and
that's really two propositions
what I have to show is that a breakup is
a workable option
and that this would likely bring a
marked improvement in human affairs
and I think the first will not be
terribly difficult to show
the second will be a little bit harder
but I hope to be able to persuade you of
that as well
to begin however let me tell you what
I'm not required to prove I'm not
required to show that there's going to
be a Civil War at the end of all of this
right
um I have been
for 74 years a Canadian and for only
eight of them an American and so I bring
a kind of Canadian Spirit about
separatism to the event
I saw how separatism can be done
peacefully and how it is discussed
peaceably
in a bunch of other countries and led to
things like the The Velvet Divorce in
the former Czech Slovakia
so I should like to think you're not
ideologically opposed to secession
right if you are uh presumably you were
opposed to Independence in 1776 because
that also was secession
so if secession were to happen here I
think it would be there wouldn't be
violence or fisticuffs it would be a
more peaceful Affairs as it would have
been in Canada
the second thing I want to say that I
don't have to prove
so I don't have to show that there's a
right to secede I don't think there is a
right to secede I think a referendum on
secession or a resolution in the state
would only begin a discussion about an
eventual breakup of the country or
dissolution of the country
right what it would lead to in fact
would be something like an article 5
Convention of the states because there
are so many things that would have to be
discussed I mean if California seceded
who gets the Pacific Fleet well not
California right and what happens to
Social Security checks I mean all of
these things have to be discussed who
you know how do you divide up the
national debt
right and the leading case on this you
know there's there are principles of
international law that apply here and
they were established by a Canadian
Supreme Court reference about uh
1998 I think and and what they said what
what the Court held is that if one part
of the country wants out and there's a
real majority for it
right it doesn't have the right to
secede because secession affects other
parts of the country as well
but it begins a process of negotiations
in short an article 5 convention now how
could an article 5 Convention of the
states mentioned in Article 5 of the U.S
Constitution be anything other than a
peaceful resolution of differences
some people will say well wait a minute
we had a case on that here in our own
country it was called Texas and white it
was 1869.
right and they held that there is no
right of secession
you know and I guess my answer uh it's
sort of the Mandy rice Davis answered
well what did you expect them to say you
know gee we're sorry South Carolina
turns out you were right all along
or you know my bad Atlanta sorry we
burned you
that wasn't an option right and moreover
I think the Canadian Supreme Court had
it right the more democratic you are
and I'm going to fall with the United
States on this the more democratic you
are the more willing you were to
tolerate that kind of a peaceful breakup
right now I'm from Virginia
and I think Virginia for example had a
right to secede in 1861.
right and I'll quote you something
somebody at the you know earlier on one
of the founders said he said the use of
force against the state now Virginia
seceded only after Lincoln called up the
troops
the use of force against the state would
look more like a declaration of war than
an infliction of punishment and would
probably be considered by the party
attacked as a dissolution of all
previous compacts
by which it might be bound
now that was James Madison
I'm sure James Madison would have said
my Virginia had a right to secede at
that time
right
but in any event we don't have to talk
about whether or not this is feasible or
workable it's an article 5 matter of
course that's within the Constitution
right and what would it lead to it would
probably lead to what the Quebec
separatists wanted which was something
called sovereignty Association
what they said is look you know there's
not going to be a unilateral secession
instead there'll be that process of
discussions where you know we get to ask
whether Quebec people still get their
Social Security checks from Ottawa stuff
like that
right so you know so if we ended up
there after an article 5 convention with
them you know would that be so bad I
mean I'll tell you one thing it led to
in Canada uh the immigration power after
after the kerfuffle about secession was
given to the provinces
now would it be so bad
to share the federal power over
immigration with States as to whether or
not they wanted immigrants or needed
immigrants I I think that would be a
marked improvement in human affairs
so that's you know my second topic it's
doable would it be a marked improvement
in human affairs
well here here the question is vague so
we have to distinguish between American
Affairs and the rest of the world
so for the rest of the world
um you know they're going to regret
having to pay their fair share of the
military budget right I mean at this
point we you know we paid 38 percent of
the world's military spending and we
bigfooted around the world we're
bigfooting it in Ukraine right now we
bigfooted it in the the second Iraq War
I think it might be a good idea to spend
less time getting people killed and more
time talking
uh through diplomacy about a solution to
some of our problems I mean we're look
we're spending three times more than the
rest of NATO put together pretty much
so how about making them pay their fair
share
what about
American Affairs okay the rest of the
world can take care of itself
What About Us
well I think I think the answer is we'd
be better off I mean that was a big
discussion in 1787 with with the framers
and the question was you know should the
country be big that was Madison the
ultra nationalist
the big loser at the convention
and opposing him was a guy called Roger
Sherman from Connecticut
who equipped montesquies said roughly
that smallest beautiful bigness is
Badness
and and I you know and I think Sherman
had the right of it here's Montesquieu
in an extensive Republic the public good
is sacrificed to a thousand private
views in a small one the interests of
the public is more obvious better
understood and more within the reach of
every citizen
it is the distance of ordinary Americans
from Washington
right
and the fact that a one-size-fits-all
government isn't Well Suited for a
country as big as ours as well as a
decline of federalism
that's led to
a number of serious problems with the
American Republic one of them is
interest group cloud is bigger
in large countries right
now I'm from George Mason so we you know
we crunch numbers
so I did some regression analysis and
all that and I found montezuke and Roger
Sherman they were right bigness is
Badness
right the smaller the country and a
sample of 150 countries the smaller the
country the wealthier it is the more
free it is
the less corrupt it is the happier it is
all that kind of stuff so in general
small is beautiful right
and we're one of the biggest countries
around
right
as for What About Us in particular or
you're saying well that's that's the
whole world What About Us in particular
well
you know I put it to you that the
federal government is oversized that it
interferes too much in local decisions
it's too remote from the people
that it attracts interest group
corruption as moths to a flame
that it goes too much abroad looking for
foreign monsters to slay
and I'd say well you know
the
idea of a movement towards secession
is worth pursuing
one last thing
what about those Mystic chords of memory
to which Lincoln referred in the first
inaugural
I didn't have much purchase in 1861
do they have any more today
Ernest Renault the French author defined
nationalism as a collective memory of
the Glorious moments in our past as well
as a certain Amnesia about the less
noble moments in our past
but when the Glorious moments and they
exist in our history are rubbished daily
in the media
and rubs in our face all the Inglorious
ones
When Calls to civility are mocked and
the principles of the founders and the
framers are scorned
then you have to ask yourself if Rana
was right
then are you or ought you to be a
separatist
for the negative uh Gerald Casey's
Gerald took it away
thank you Gene thank you Frank
oh yeah I forget how tall I am sometimes
it was the best of times it was the
worst of times it's the age of wisdom
was the age of foolishness it was the
Epic of belief was the Epic of
incredulity the season of light was a
season of Darkness Charles Dickens which
capture the the
excuse me the pessimism and optimism of
nearly every generation
but it does feel like we live in
extraordinary times
culture and politics changing what
seemed like an ever increasing Pace a
political landscape of the United States
is often vitriolic with our two major
political parties abandoning the
moderate voter in favor of their
extremities
because during Times Like These the talk
of Americans breaking up the American
Union began to circulate
secession and National divorce have
always been a part of the American
Consciousness and nearly every
generation has some flirtation with the
idea
as Paul as the political and cultural
Wars rage around us we need to take a
clear-eyed look at how National breakup
would work and what the real world
outcome would be
as a Libertarian I hold individual
liberty as the highest political aim
and so while decentralization of power
can increase excuse me so while
decentralization of power can increase
freedom decentralization of the limits
on power can decrease it the greatest
possible cheat Improvement in human
Affairs is that every person is able to
pursue their own interests as long as
they don't harm anyone else to this end
government should be limited to
protecting life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
Authority should only extend as far as
is necessary to defend each person's
rights whether a country is the size of
a continent or is the size of a
neighborhood
individual liberty must be protected
trading one federal government for
multiple Federal governments as a
national divorce would do brings a great
deal of questions and secession will not
eliminate all of the things that the
federal government currently does these
new governments would handle welfare
National Defense border control trade
agreements military alliances national
debt and a myriad of other policies is
how these new governments would handle
these issues that would ultimately
determine the outcome of a national
Breakout
so let's take a look at the resolution
which says the breakup of the United
States into different regions is a
workable option likely to bring a marked
improvement in human affairs
essentially it asked if breaking up the
United States into multiple new federal
governments is regionally and
politically possible and whether or not
the result would lead to an improvement
in human Affairs the resolution is not a
discussion about the theory of
decentralization itself but about the
application of the theory in the current
world
the resolution has a large-scale
realignment or separation of the states
of the Union the resolution provides
three tests that must be met three
burdens of proof that the affirmative
must show the first burden is that there
are definable and workable regions in
the United States that it could be
broken into the second is that the
breakup must be politically workable and
the third is that it would bring a
marked improvement in human Affairs in
the foreseeable future
if each of these tests are not met by
the affirmative if it fails to
demonstrate each and every one then the
resolution fails as a whole
this will not be an argument against all
regional breakups or secession in fact
these can be useful tools to increasing
human Prosperity but while we may
appreciate the end of the federal
government our desires of where we want
to go must come second to a clear-eyed
look at the world as it is not as we
wish it to be
decentralization and secession are not
in and of themselves they are tools and
as such they must be judged on the real
world outcomes when it's just policies
by the results not their intentions
so a national so is a national breakup
regionally workable much of the regional
workability of a Nation a national
breakup rests on the ability to figure
out where these new borders would start
and where they would end borders that
ignore cultural and political realities
can cause Strife for generation
the partitions of India separating it
from Pakistan displaced 15 million
people in cost over a million lives
the breakup of the Balkans cost over a
hundred thousand lives and the area has
since suffered suffered a 14 decline in
their population
the cultural History of the United
States is one of multiculturalism a
giant Melting Pot of people from every
corner
so historical historical examples of
national breakup provide little answers
for us since they happen along cultural
lines the breakup of Czechoslovakia was
between the Czechs and slovaks
Yugoslavia was divided among the Bosnia
ex-creations macedonia's Montenegro
slovenians and serbians the Soviet Union
was devised of split among dozens of
cultures and languages many of him many
of whom had their own countries before
and comparing an American breakup to
decolonization is comparing apples and
oranges colonies are geographically and
culturally split from the ruling country
and members of The Colony are often
second-class citizens
the disillusion of the French Spanish
and British colonial empires provide
little comparison to American today so
history has very few examples of Finney
that resemble what an American breakup
would look like
so where are these lines along which the
U.S could be divided the current
political division within the U.S is
often perceived to be between red and
blue States
but if there's a divide to be found it's
between it's not between regions States
or regions of States it's between urban
and rural areas
Urban voters vote Democrat at 62 percent
rule voters vote Republican at 54 and
the suburbs are split right down the
middle
this is not a unique situation to the
United States nearly every nation has a
political difference between its rural
and urban population
so if we divided this country along
state lines or even regions of States
rural areas and red States would be
handed more control over the urban areas
and urban States and blue areas
will be handed more control over the
rural areas giving one side more control
over the other is a recipe for Strife
not Peace So regardless of whether it's
two new nations or 50 a national breaker
would increase political tensions not
decrease them
is a national breakup politically
workable one barrier is that you have to
convince a large portion of the
population of us of a region that they
should succeed
and you have to convince a large portion
of the other region to let them
if America is so truly divided as
National divorce Advocates claim how can
a consensus be reached imagine trying to
convince the rural areas of democrat
states that they should be left behind
by the Republicans in the in the urban
areas of the Republican states that they
should be left behind by the Democrats
you will always have a large percentage
of the population of each state that
will inevitably opposed secession
for example if we divided the States
along the 2020 election lines between
red and blue States we would have over
66 million voters caught on the wrong
side of this new border and is not
unreasonable to expect that this would
be fairly representative representative
of the entire population
which means that 42 percent of Americans
or 138 million of us would be caught on
the wrong side and that number doesn't
include independent voters
supporters of national breakup try to
solve this by claiming that there would
be a domino effect of one
decentralization leading to further
decentralization but this is entirely
without historical evidence it ignores
basic political reality when a new
nation is created it does not suddenly
have a motivation to divide itself nor
would there be much of any popular
motivation for another breakup political
divisions even peaceful ones are often
economically and culturally stressful
any motivation to divide further would
require each new country to have a new
set of cultural divisions to provoke a
breakup
new nations are founded out of new ideas
and cultural identities so any further
division would have to undermine the
very idea ideas and cultural divisions
that provoke the first uh that the new
nation was founded on
essentially the popularity of the things
that made the first breakup happen would
prevent the next Breakout
and the historical trend of new
countries is not to divide further but
the opposite direction to unite with
other nations
after after the world wars the new
European nations immediately sought to
join other nations and military
alliances and economic unions this
eventually led to the European Union
which has itself become increasingly
centralized just yeah and we have the
association of Southeast Nations the
African Union countless military
alliances among small Nations a national
breakup is neither protection from from
future centralization nor is it a
guarantee of further decentralization
so will the National breakup lead to an
improvement in human Affairs we
currently have near perfect free trade
within the United States with access to
a broad swath of resources and human
capital even these new even if these new
federal governments were committed to
free trade and movement there would
still be a reduction in the the ability
to trade freely
new tariffs customs and differences in
regulatory practices would impose large
costs on those who trade and transport
across state borders red States would
undoubtedly move to restrict immigration
as much as possible especially if blue
States opened up to non-american
migrants
and restrictions between these new
federal governments would mean border
checkpoints between regions the
thousands of miles of new borders would
mean would come with a large cost to
human prosperity
American politics currently benefit from
the ballots of power between the two
authoritarian parties which inhibit many
of their worst impulses from an
individual liberty perspective
Republicans are at their best when
they're stopping Democrats and Democrats
are the best when they are stopping
Republicans upsetting that balance and
giving one half the country to one side
and half to the other would enable
greater authoritarianism which would not
be an improvement in human affairs
in the formation of these new federal
governments it would not be some new
crop of politicians to lead us to a
brighter future in fact it would be the
exact same politicians who got us in
this mess
the Constitutions of these new federal
governments would be written by the
Nancy Pelosi's and Kevin McCarthy's of
the world not the Thomas Jefferson's and
James Madison's
for example the same politicians trying
to regulate speech at the state level as
they've tried in Texas and California
and Florida
would be in charge of rewriting the
First Amendment for the new federal
governments
our national divorce is a path towards
more individual individual liberty only
if you trust our current politicians
if we had politicians who were
interested in true decentralization
further and further down to the
individual nothing what would stop them
under the from doing so under the
current federal framework there's
nothing stopping our politicians from
taking power from the federal government
and giving it back to the states and the
states then giving power back to the
localities so if we had politicians who
were truly interested in decentralizing
down to the event individual we would
not need a national breakup to do it
even if this domino effect of
decentralization existed merely
localizing government control over your
life is not true decentralization of
power
while in theory this gives you more
control over your government it gives
the same control to your local Lakeway
Karen letting your neighbors instead of
Albany or DC dictate what you say or do
is not true decentralization
in fact some of the worst abuses of your
rice come from already localized parts
of government local and state law
enforcement zoning laws and occupational
licensing are far more likely to impact
your day-to-day life than the federal
government National divorce won't make
the DMV any better
True decentralization Lies not in giving
your city government or your state
government more power over you true
decentralization is letting each and
every individual make their own
decisions about their own lives
based on their own interests
the ultimate decentralization is found
in the protection of inalienable rights
not in the population size of a Nation
we'd be very clear clear this is not a
call for violent conquest of others nor
on those who wish to secede this is
advocacy for policies that have a true
proven track record of true
decentralization in the real world
through protection of individual liberty
for each with free trade free free
markets and free migration
so we're left looking for the answers to
the question asked by the resolution is
the national divorce is a national
breakup regionally workable is it
politically workable and will lead to an
improvement in human affairs
or we can theorize about arriving at a
destination how we want to if there's no
path to that destination then it is not
workable nor does it have any chance of
leading to the intended result there's
no magic button to a press to achieve a
desired end we are either progressing
toward a world we want or we are
regressing away from it at best national
breakup of the United States is merely a
lateral move and with this outcome
entirely dependent on the political
realities of the world we live in it
would be a move backwards
merely giving people a choice in a red
flavor of tyranny or a blue flavor of
tyranny will not lead to an improvement
of human Affairs this is not to say that
a breakup is never an option or should
always be opposed individuals have the
right to secede but they also have the
right to not succeed so we are caught
between competing rights if we secede we
violate the rights of those who wish to
remain and if we remain we violate the
rights of those who wish to secede so
what should those of us who respect
individual liberty do the only
justification to overrule the choice of
others in seceding or not seceding is to
be able to demonstrate that our choice
would provide more individual liberty
we simply cannot make any such
justification for the breakup of the
United States in its current political
climate
despite claims to the contrary there's
no magical population size of gov of a
nation that increases human prosperity
to its maximum the principles that make
a nation truly conducive for human
Prosperity don't change because of the
size of its population what makes a
nation truly conducive for human
Prosperity are the true liberal
principles of restricting government to
protecting life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
these principles have created the most
prosperous and peaceful time in human
history unlike liberalisms counterparts
which claim that they need full
implementation of their ideas to be
successful even when partially adopted
these principles have led to
unparalleled results for Humanity
regardless of a nation's number of
humans those Nations which allow
individuals to pursue their own
interests as long as they don't harm
anybody else
will see the greatest Improvement in
human affairs
you can do different Podium or either
way but yeah but five minutes of
rebuttal from Frank
well thank you so much for that although
I I'm I think I missed something because
I kept listening for you to say uh as
I'm a Libertarian that's why I'm a
secessionist but I I didn't hear that
right it just
something was missing there was one
other thing
that I thought
I wasn't required to respond to but I
will in a way and the question is well
will it ever happen
right would you ever get a bunch of
people in a state voting for a secession
and I think what's behind that is the
natural assumption
life is flatlined
right there'll never be any Peaks and
valleys and real estate prices it's
always the same thing
whereas in reality
the only thing that is flatlined is your
ECG when you die
so anything can happen
nobody thought in Spring of 1861 that
we'd have secession
all right James Buchanan said I don't
see why you're doing this I don't think
you have the right to do it but no
country better protects slavery than the
United States he was right
even Abraham Lincoln was willing to
concede the point
take a look at the first inaugural
Lincoln is saying I have no intention of
interfering with slavery moreover he
said I am willing to sign a 13th
Amendment which will guarantee the right
of slavery forever in the United States
that's Lincoln
in April 1861.
all right
would it happen today well you know
that's not part of what we're debating
but you know it
to clarify things you know
how might this happen
well there were amongst Democrats
Syria's talk about secession of
California if Donald Trump won the 2020
election
right all the Democratic bigwigs said
the big brains had plotted this out and
they thought that would be kind of a
logical thing to do at this time
and what would happen if California
seceded well you you know you you'd end
up with an article 5 convention which
was the idea proposed by there's never
too much to be praised George Mason okay
and uh and we have to divide things up
as as they would in Canada we don't
they're out there also there would be
one big winner
U-Haul
it's happening now of course between
Texas and California and that's what
accelerated
this is what I saw in Canada
right I mean a separatist francophone
bottle francophone government was
elected in Quebec
and we said right you know what do we do
about that well about 300 000 anglos
moved to Toronto you know which is
almost a face fate worse than death
and for the rest of us those who stayed
my colleagues who I I taught law up
there
right
we kind of looked at each other and we
realized some of us are separatists and
some of us are not and we thought well
that's not going to get in the way of
our friendship
I gather by the way the the Habs
dressing room had the same discussion
right we're all friends
except there's none of that in America
today
I've seen such divisions amongst
Americans
and such bitterness
of a kind that I never saw when
separatism was seriously discussed
in Quebec
so you have to ask are we ready for it
foreign
[Applause]
what I didn't hear in that
was my answer to any of my three
questions that I asked is it is it
regionally workable
where do you divide the lines is it
politically workable
and will lead to a an improvement in
human affairs
when you divide up the nation you you
take it out you take a a state or a
region you take it out from the United
States it doesn't have access to the
same free trade free migration human
capital that you want to have before
I do want to address the one point about
the
um about whether or not we you know our
vitriol and our politics today and I am
just like you I'm very concerned with it
as well
but I want to read to you a few things
that have been said
by past past politicians to each other
Thomas Jefferson hired a journalist to
write about John Adams
calling him a hideous hermaphroditical
character who has neither the force and
firmness of a man nor the gentleness and
Sensibility of a woman
in 1828 election
a cartoon was published showing Andrew
Jackson lynching John Quincy Adams I
don't know why they went after The Adams
Family so much but in that same election
this was published General Jackson's
mother was a common prostitute
brought to this country by the British
soldiers
she afterwards married a mulatto man who
had wished she had who with whom she had
several children of which General
Jackson is one
in 1920s Senator Thomas helfin gave the
speech about a potential Presidential
nominee if Alfred E Smith the wet romish
East Side Tammany Hall candidate is
nominated it will be on account of the
Roman influence speaking about the
Catholic Church
in Houston I will use all my influence
all my power speech to prevent his
nomination but if he succeeds it will
mean that the Pope's agent is in the
White House
I don't think I need to go into the
history of American racism and politics
we've had some pretty bad history of
that been pretty evil to each other and
awful to each other I don't know that
it's changed
I don't know that's changed that much I
think that our social media certainly
exacerbates some of those issues and
puts it on the front page and certainly
you know the the
uh promote some of the wrong things
but I don't know that we've actually
changed that much in 250 Years thank you
[Applause]
um thank you to you both we now move to
the Q a uh portion of the evening and uh
those of you uh who've done it know to
line up behind that mic for the Q a and
uh there could be some questions from
the streamers and uh maybe somebody from
the balcony wants to ask a question I do
want to start however with moderators
prerogative and ask the uh a question of
um of Frank Buckley uh
the the uh the complaint on the part of
your opponent
has been that any way of dividing up the
countries of geographically would mean
uh that a lot of people are going to be
left in different regions you know we
Libertarians will be left in New York
and be dominated by a bunch of
socialists and so on uh can you maybe
briefly outline what kind of regions do
you think could uh be divided up uh with
the continental United States if you
want to throw in Hawaii in Alaska that's
fine and what would happen to the people
who might be disaffected in any
particular region
Frank what's on yeah God yes
yes well you know the one thing that
does give me pause about all the
business I thought that we're a
succession to happen I might have to
move to Oklahoma
but I don't really know if it's going to
be all that bad I think I take issue
um with my colleague as to how rotten
the United States is
um
Joe Biden the other days said there are
still people who want to Lynch people
and I don't think that I you know I
maybe you know some I don't I don't
think you do either actually
you see one of the reasons why secession
might seem attractive is because the
Civil Rights revolution has taken hold
right it's not as if we're going back to
1861 or to the slavery that Lincoln was
willing to tolerate
right it's it's we're in a thankfully
much different country than we were even
60 years ago
right and we're you know we're in all
parts of the country still evolving in
in all of these ways
so I I think we can put that out of our
mind you know in you know indeed frankly
in Quebec uh
nobody was being
a dictatorial about any of this it was a
debate amongst liberals
right I had in Quebec libertarian
friends of mine who were separatists
they were anglos and they said imagine
getting rid of one level of government
out of crack how good is that
so you know when you recognize that what
we're not talking about is Fort Sumter
or even the invasion of my city of
Alexandria
in April 24 1861
it's a very hard thing
to be invaded
no I I I don't think that would happen I
think the stakes are lower I think
U-Haul would make out well as it is now
and I think if it happened what we'd be
more likely talking about
is a more politically correct succession
of the left on a republican victory of
the presidency
in which case I suspect a Republican
president would say something like don't
let the door hit you on the way out
I push your second Frank a little bit
more on that could you could you take a
stab you mentioned California seceding
could you take a stab at imagining uh
approximately what kind of geographical
breakup could occur plausibly and well
there are all sorts of possibilities I
mean give us your favorite
give us your fat Jimmy sorry
your favorite go ahead okay well as you
know there are all sorts of interesting
possibilities here in uh Western uh
Oregon
they want to join Idaho
right that strikes me as a little
perverse I have no desire to join Idaho
I don't know if any of you do I don't
quite see the attraction of grossa Idaho
but I guess if the alternative is
Eastern Oregon that may make some sense
these things are possible as well there
may be that kind of sorting out some of
it may happen in in California right
there are parts of California which
continue to elect Republicans it gets
smaller and smaller
you have in Texas
um you know keep it weird Austin
well maybe maybe they'll have to move
back to San Francisco or Los Angeles I
don't know
but we do sort ourselves out you know I
mean about 60 percent of Americans
American residents live in a state other
than the one they grew up in right
somewhere born in other countries
we move around right there's a lot of
t-boost sorting that that happens all
the time
and this would accelerated
um I think
in terms of civil rights
the state's Stakes would not be of a
kind you describe
but there would be I think a benign
competition for a more efficient kind of
state
one where the heavy hand of one size
fits all rule from Washington is
weakened and I think that would be a
good thing
you've mentioned uh you maybe push you
for a little further you you've covered
the West Coast Frank could you cover the
east coast in Midwest and South well I'd
like to get West Virginia back if you
want to know that I mean the scandal in
which a trumped-up government
in Alex in Alexandria Virginia purported
to represent the state and to accede to
the departure of West Virginia still
still rankles okay
you know you know it by the way as
Jefferson was mentioned you know it
might not be a bad thing to remember
just how secession has been a running
theme
in our Affairs the Jefferson of the
Kentucky resolves of 1798 the Jefferson
who supported nullification
would I think that fire Bell in the
night Jefferson would I think have been
more than happy to join the Confederacy
or had he been alive at that time
so you go through American history and
you'll find the arguments the
Constitutional Arguments for secession
are much stronger than you might have
thought they were
and and they still are there you know I
mean if as an American Supreme Court had
to think about this I I think it would
have to
consider that Texas be white was per and
curium wrongly decided
you know what you know how they got
there
that Texas case in 1869 that said
there's no right of secession what you
know what they did
they went back to the old articles
the Articles of Confederation that said
that they were
going to create a Perpetual Union
okay
now some of you will remember hey I
teach law that you know this is okay I'm
sorry this is too much like home
um the Articles of Confederation
specified that they could not be amended
except by a unanimous vote of all 13
provinces
okay George Washington the the con the
Constitution provided it came into
effect when nine states agreed
right nine states agreed in 1788 George
Washington was elected in 1789 Rhode
Island ratified the Constitution the
last state in 1790. in short if you buy
that argument George Washington's first
term was a nullity
pushing one further step Frank what what
was what's going to happen to the
Northeast uh the South where are they
going to go you think approximately uh
if there's a secession
I'm a law professor what the hell do I
know don't know okay you know I I
States will sort them would sort
themselves out and you might find
strange alliances like what of States
finding themselves more willing to
belong to Florida than to New York
okay
coming from you Gerald
what was the question the question is
how would you imagine a breakup would
happen geographically
I don't imagine it that's why I'm on
this side of the debate oh you
you don't think you you your position is
it it ain't gonna happen you're making a
prediction if it could happen Frank
mentioned that
that the world is cyclical things go
through Cycles things go up things go
down I completely agree with him on that
so it's just Michael did yeah a little
more yeah there we go so yes things are
more things are cyclical things go
through their their phases goes ups and
downs in popularity of things
but I don't see it happening in our in
our current climate we we have we're two
we're too integrated across cultures
we're too integrated with our cities and
our towns we've got so much going on we
can't you're not going to be able to
divide up the country in any way
that's going to make the make the social
climate any better you're going to have
you're going to increase the you're
going to increase the tensions I mean
you say you move to a new state
that's 168 million people are going to
find themselves on the wrong side of the
line now now sure 20 years from now the
electric might look different
but right now it doesn't
question uh from the audience
well I think
Gene covered a lot of the territory I
was going to ask about but I think uh Mr
Buckley your
uh initial proposition is that was that
smaller was better when you when you
started your argument
I think most of us have thought about
secession or breakup of the United
States have thought about red versus
blue which is a breakup into two but are
you more of thinking like a breakup into
10 or 20 different pieces or or how many
are you thinking about well you got to
start somewhere
I I confess that at you know the Realms
of
High fancy where we imagine events which
we could not conceivably begin to
predict leave me silent
yeah you don't know it could be 10 20
you're not sure yeah it could be
anything any any possible any
combination
[Music]
you know Vermont I guess still retains
the possibility of joining Canada
doesn't it something something like that
I mean
you know there are all these Northeast
resentments you know
um
Boston versus New York God knows how it
might end up once you get started that'd
be the fun of it
question yeah could I could I answer
that real quick okay so the idea that
smaller is better he mentions uh
corruption and happiness but you want to
solve for corruption you don't just nuke
the country you don't break it off you
do you you implement policies and
transparencies to deal with corruption
same with happiness the US's 18th I
think it was on your study it's 18th on
your on his study of happiness in the in
the world
we are higher than 259 or something
other countries
maybe our happiness is because we're one
country we don't know
as far as as far as whether or not an
approve you know an improvement in human
Affairs in my view that's individual
liberty if you look at Cato's
institute's uh human Freedom index the
population statistically explains only
two percent of the variants you find
that's statistically meaningless
same with the Hue the uh for the Freedom
House Freedom in the world population
explains less than one percent
of the statistical variance in National
freedom score
these are not these are not
statistically significant
so I think what what it doesn't matter
if Europe is better off smaller in
smaller Nations it matters whether if we
break up will we be better off not
whether Europe is better enough small
you want a comment Frank no we have a
question
there's the idea of kind of Laboratories
that the different states could be if
they were separate countries so you have
New Hampshire and you have the free
state movement there and you could
imagine them you know getting rid of the
FDA or Free banking or all sorts of
things I'm wondering what you guys can
Envision on that and whether you think
that's a good reason for breaking things
up well jurisdictional competition is a
proposition with a lot of economic
evidence behind it in in a number of
areas
uh you know corporate law for example
indeed the person I regard as the
inventor of public Choice Frederick
Jackson Turner
said that jurisdictional competition was
employed by Western States to attract
people from Eastern states away from
their hide-bound aristocratic tendencies
right and by the way Turner said the
effect moved all the way back to the old
world it All Began in the frontier and
I'm from the West so I I buy into that
uh but by the way uh as to how we rank
generally
when you look at rankings produced by
darn near everyone Cara Heritage Cato
Freedom House
we suck basically at least you know in
amongst First World countries we do
really really poorly in so many areas
uh K-12 education is scandalous Where We
Are
right anything that brings power more
towards people
in choices like that would be a
wonderful thing and getting out of the
Department of Education would be a nice
first step
comment I agree with your last comment
for sure but but our education system is
already decentralized we have states
that control their local education
systems we have local school boards that
look that control their local local
schools so our education system is
already decentralized it's breaking up
the country is not really going to
decentralize it that much sure we get
rid of the Department of Education which
I'm all for but I'd like to go back to
the question uh real quick which is
essentially you know where the federal
government you know the benefits of
federal government
experiments in the states right
the federal government in my view should
only be should be limited to only
performing the functions that the
federal government can do National
Defense holding the state's feet to the
fire as far as you know constitutional
law
um and a handful of other things and so
you know sorting out differences between
the states and that's one thing that we
do have to take into account especially
with the world changing as it is we're
going to have issues with water rights
there's there's court case in the
Supreme Court right now over water
rights between I think it's between
California or um
Colorado and there's a few states around
there because this is a big issue if we
break up we won't have the Supreme Court
goat to go to to talk about these things
and figure out a peaceful solution
so in the future you know looking
forward in a national divorce that is a
problem
you want to make a comments right no
just on the on the point of National
Defense
um
you know I ran the numbers on this and
large countries spend much more on their
military than small countries
um if you're Luxembourg or if you're
Canada you don't have Imperial ambitions
but the larger the country curiously the
bigger the the military budget I think
it's about Glory right it's a word one
doesn't hear much but a word that's
extremely important
there's a lot of
chest thumping over America's position
in the world and this describes big
countries in general what are the big
countries in the world
while America China Russia of course
but even India India thinks the Indian
Ocean it's it's their Mary nostrum
right you have a temptation to Greatness
to Glory that goes with bigness
and I'm with John Quincy Adams on that
one I don't I think we too much go
abroad looking for foreign monsters to
destroy
question
in The Federalist Papers Alexander
Hamilton argues a little bit into the
night I'm sorry in The Federalist Papers
Alexander Hamilton argues in between
being several different confederacies
versus being a single uh United States
and his argument is that if we are
several confederacies then we would
commonly go to war over resources over
um skirmishes but between the different
confederacies in the same way that is
happening in Europe
um do you think that if we are if there
is a separation into different
confederacies that we would be able to
avoid that that having the national
government it would be a good thing to
um keep peace between the states that
now exist
well you got me started on that one okay
uh The Federalist Papers were largely
unknown even at the time damn it
but throughout the 19th century you know
how they were discovered they were
discovered by Charles beard in 1911 and
said here it is here's the inflection
point in the marxian stages of
capitalism here's where America becomes
sheds its Agri agrarian past and becomes
Mercantile
and that's somehow they get the
Federalist Papers get picked up by the
right
I don't know why
is it is there something about the
separation of powers
that appeals to you
if so you might ask yourself why
the 20 odd countries that rank ahead of
us on rankings of Freedom are all
non-separation of powers to countries
with an all-powerful House of Commons
many of which are monarchies now as for
Hamilton
right Hamilton
so embarrassed himself in front of the
other framers that he left early on June
30 1787.
right
Hamilton had argued there should be only
one Sovereign there can be only one
Sovereign it's what the Brits said to us
in 1776. you have to have one Sovereign
it must be the United States I would
abolish the states he said
I would abolish the states now I
wouldn't entirely get rid of them
because you know you need these
subsidiary organizations even as
Virginia needs cities like Arlington and
Alexandria and and has those
cities do things that aren't done by
Richmond so too Hamilton said we'll have
a sovereign United States government
which will allow the states to exist and
to perform and delegate to them
some responsibilities
I mentioned that because
we live in a hamiltonian republic don't
we does not describe American federalism
uh but to put a final point on the
question uh Frank the concern expressed
was that if say there are five to ten
different countries in the Continental
what is now the continental United
States that there would be difficulties
of trade and possibly
squabbling between the various countries
they wouldn't get along that could be
even Wars in 1787 contemplated the
breakup of the country
um there were big arguments about that
Governor Morris threatened to hang some
people
in the debates
well most people thought there were
three natural divisions in the United
States in 1787. there was the South a
land of gentlemen and slaves
there were the middle colonies New York
and Pennsylvania commercial
and then you had people in New England
who mostly fished I guess I don't know
um or get went to congregationalist
churches so you know everybody at the
time everybody thought yeah of course we
could break up
right uh any by the way so any supreme
court today composed of originalists
who thought they should be faithful to
the thinking of the framers would
concede a righteous recession exists
you don't anticipate war between the
various countries that the continental
United States would break up into well
look the Loyalists talk about sore
losers
okay
uh Sir John Graves Simcoe said well you
know they're they they've obviously
blown it they'll come to their senses
and then then they'll they'll invite us
back to you know rule them
um but in fact America didn't have to
fear
foreign countries it was Canada that had
to feel American invade fear and
Invasion from America
Washington had it right we were
separated from Europe and all its
conflicts and it's silly to throw that
away
equipment from you Charles about the
question about providing up the
countries right so essentially would we
would we find ourselves in conflict
between states is that correct
yes okay internal conflicts yeah so
essentially yeah you would have some
conflicts I don't know how they would be
resolved I would hope that if we did
find ourselves in a national divorce
situation that would be it would be a
peaceful one and we could go our
separate ways peacefully but that's not
a guarantee there could be you know as
we've talked about things just cyclical
things do change over time if there is a
violent if there is violence between the
states and separation then absolutely it
won't be any Good Will in any conflicts
further down the line and as far as
during
um
um uh during the Articles of
Confederation there were conflicts
between the states in those days that
did break out into fighting they were
mostly small but they did happen
question
Roman Maxine God yes
could somebody lower the mic to her uh
please uh yes
um so this question is specifically for
the affirmative you mentioned the
national debt and Social Security but
what actual resolutions are there
um to untangling our fiscal policies
with individuals in different potential
new States
uh your question is how would we divide
up uh Social Security in the national
debt things like that yeah yes How would
how do we deal with that so something
that is going to have to be discussed by
the parties it was
it was a
matter of throwing us all into
hodgepodge
as
Patterson said in 1787.
um and these things would have to be
sorted out there are a number of ways
upon which you could sort out the
national debt
um
and it would be messy
but both the seceding State and the rest
of the United States would have a say in
the matter
so I don't know how that would work out
it's it's something that
the Brits would have to figure out if
Scotland succeeds
it's something the Spanish would have to
figure out if Catalonia's the seeds
it's something they did sort out I'm not
quite sure how
as between the Czech Republic and
Slovakia
so you know the these things are
discussable as the French say
come in
I mean as far as social security goes I
think that it's the answer there is to
privatize it let's get the government
out of it all together but as far as
national debt that is a very difficult
answer that's not something that a news
nation is not going to saddle itself
with debt it's a lot of debt I don't
know if anybody's noticed but it's big
comment question yeah
I I think a lot of these issues uh
practical ones the debt all that stuff
is a smoke screen we have mergers all
the time and Acquisitions and
dispositions that deal with issues like
that my concern and what I was hoping to
hear that I didn't hear is
it's not based on fishing or agriculture
if there is a philosophical difference
in this country if you have part of the
country that believes that the federal
government should tell everybody what to
do in another part of the country that's
libertarian is for individual liberties
or whatever then the country has a
reason to break up people will
understand that and if you're on the
wrong side of it that's not a problem I
don't know why we care of 168 million
people on the wrong side they're on the
wrong side of it today we're New Yorkers
stuck living on a living in in a
philosophy that we don't want to live in
so my question is if you had an
underlying philosophy that allowed a
country based upon two different major
principles and by the way they both
couldn't keep the Constitution one
country will define the constitution as
it is now the other one will define the
constitution as a it was originally
intended to be why under those
circumstances couldn't this work
that's a question for you Gerald
I agree entirely with that ah yes he
made your case very eloquently Frank
good yes
well we talk about a philosophical
divide in this country but it's not
between authoritarians and Libertarians
between authoritarians and
authoritarians
Republicans are just they're
authoritarians in their way and liberals
or I shouldn't say liberals right should
progressives are authoritarian in their
own ways that's not the Divide is not
one part of the country wants to be
Freer they just want to be Freer in
their way
that's the problem we have is that we we
if we had a side that was truly
libertarian that did want to reduce
reduce government control over your life
and not just reduce it in ways that you
personally would and you're fine with
government trampling on other people's
rights then sure that would be a
different situation but that's not what
we had today today we have two parties
that are intent on forcing their moral
fiber on you their their moral beliefs
on you both sides are and that's not
that's not a that's not a decision I
want to make I don't want to have to
choose
between having my children go to a
school that where they're forced to say
the product of Allegiance and or in a
part of the country that they've forced
to say some won't pledge I don't want
either of those
have you thought of moving to Canada
repeat that Frank I didn't hear it
repeat what you said Frank would you
repeat what you said I didn't hear it
no okay okay
you'll all tell me later what he said I
questioned
hi question for uh the gentleman arguing
for the resolution
um you had argued in your in your
opening remarks uh actually ceded that
um that second point on the resolution
around the prosperity of I forget the
wording exactly well raise the mic a
little bit raise your mind raise the mic
too it's so cool raise the mic to face
raise the mic okay all right can you do
that yeah good idea yeah yeah great yes
thank you can you hear me okay
uh so you would you had seeded that uh
other members of NATO for instance would
most likely have to pay their fair share
their you know greater portion of
national International defense funds and
I wonder how you see secession impacting
uh the International Community on the
point of human Prosperity uh when we
have Rising hegemons notably China that
may instead exert greater influence than
other NATO member states
and given their track record on human
prosecutive human rights well that's
that's a a good question I would think
that other countries would have to step
up more to the plate and I averted to
the dangers of an America that thinks it
can Bigfoot everything
including problems which I think would
be better suited to be held dealt with
at a diplomatic level such as such as
Ukraine
uh as for China
well um
the countries of NATO are starting to
respond to that with aircraft carriers
and the like
I don't
like I confess I don't have an easy
answer to that particular one apart from
the fact that America does not exist in
the world to counter China
coming agreed we shouldn't be the police
of the world we shouldn't be the ones
saying telling everybody we will defend
you I think that one of the reasons that
Russia felt empowered to invade Ukraine
was because we had been funding NATO and
so NATO looked weak if we had either
left NATO or pushed you pushed NATO to
fund itself more
Russia may not have been in a position
or may not have thought that it was able
to take over to invade Ukraine so I
think that's you know our policing
around the world does put our allies at
risk sometimes I think I can speak to
that I have 30 seconds in the Trump uh
campaign I was the most pro-russian
person and indeed wrote the foreign
policy speech for the candidate
and thought as we all did at the time on
the team that a peace treaty in which
Putin kept the Crimea
was the only kind of solution
in short diplomacy
and we may get there I expect we will
but only after so many people have been
killed
uh next question yeah
hi um my question is for the negative
um there is a lot of cultural animosity
between the two parties right now if we
stay together as a country how does that
calm down if can you outline like two
specific examples of how we can have
more of a common Heritage common
national identity maybe we get back into
Civic nationalism something like that
for both blue states red States blue
culture red culture yeah I mean it's
talking to each other
like that's that's the answer now listen
we have this idea we have this idea that
cultural Strife is bad
was the gay rights movement bad
was the Civil Rights Movement bad was
the women's rights movement bad
was abolition bad no these are all
horrifically strike you know uh painful
events in our cultural history
doesn't mean they were bad
now this isn't to say that every
cultural Strife is good for us doesn't
mean that it always leads to good
results but sometimes they do and we
have to take that seriously
you know Martin Luther King was a junior
was he was the most hated man in America
when he died
I think that's Pleasant
you think that's good that looks good to
us no we look horrible
but it so when we strive for these
things we have to take a look at should
we as a culture be learning something
so it's it's it's it's it's it's coming
together and again talking to each other
um uh the uh we have a final question
here ask the question I'm afraid it's
going to have to be answered in the
summaries but would you please pose the
question sure
um hi this is for the negative a lot of
your debate was your other reasoning was
that if we break into two we cannot
reasonably expect that there will be
further breakups and some of it was
around like if you do a divide between
blue and red and a lot of people would
be on the wrong side of the Border what
is unworkable about dividing a country
into
a number of pieces each representing
some ideological faction right and as
Professor Frank said we can kind of
basically make U-Haul a big company and
move people around so that you're all
kind of affiliated with the political
belief that yeah I mean uh you're
allowed to answer that question in your
summary because we're out of time for
the Q a uh so now we go to the summary
portion of the evening
please well thank you all thank you for
those great questions
I'm going to ask you to vote
for the proposition that I defended
I think I've established that this is
constitutionally feasible
as an article 5 matter
and I've tried to persuade you that it
might be or it would be desirable as
well
I concentrated on Americans more than
the rest of the world but I think
generally
it can easily be argued that this would
be a benign thing
for for both
but
let me leave you with one last thought
if there are amongst you
people who remember an earlier America
and who have the sense that without
leaving America America left them
that they
when they were young lived in a country
where people were proud
of the Glorious events in the country
who were aware
of all the problems but took pride
and how we
began to solve all of those problems
if there are people amongst you who
remember a time
when if you met a stranger you looked
upon him
as a potential friend a colleague an
ally another American
not as a
possible enemy a person who hates you
if there are amongst you people
who would like to go back to that
earlier time
then I tell you you cannot go back
I tell you that if you want what it's
natural
to create that kind of community
and that kind of solidarity the most
basic one of the most basic of human
desires
that you have to think more creatively
about other ways of
bonding with each other
and for that reason I ask you to support
the affirmative in this question
John
[Applause]
seem to have gotten things out of order
here I think I got it now
a few months ago my daughter she's eight
she's looking at me scrolling over my
phone and I happen to scroll past the
announcement for this event
she's like what's that well it's
National divorce she's like well what's
that
so I explained the idea to her and she
goes the end of it she goes no sir we
would have to we would have to show
papers when we went to see Grandma and
Grandpa in Missouri
well she understood
was it dividing up families is bad
and what we need to understand is that
fighting up individuals and businesses
is also bad
the affirmative has not shown any of the
three answered any of the three
questions that I asked is it regionally
workable is it politically workable or
will it lead to an improvement in human
affairs
on regionality
we'll figure it out that's the only
answer we could get
and the fact of the matter is these are
millions of lives we're talking about
we can't simply figure it out we have to
plan for it we have to talk about it
think about about how these things would
actually take place
can't just wave these answers off
I'd like to end with a word of caution
to the proponents of national breakup
that it would not be them who are in
control of the outcome
there's no Garden of Eden just for us to
plug in the right formula to
there's notes one simple trick in the
path to Liberty
something claimed that a breakup would
make it easier for Libertarians to
influence government and its citizens
but as I pointed out earlier the reverse
is also true makes it easier for
authoritarians as well
one does not have to be a great student
of History to understand that the
protection of individual liberty doesn't
come from nowhere
burning a system down without any plan
for the aftermath will only create a
power backing for something far worse to
fill
there are those that argue that the
constitution has failed in his job of
protecting our rights and so it should
be abandoned but as any good historian
will always ask compared to what
what other document has provided for so
much Liberty for so long and do we
really trust our current politicians to
improve on it the reality is that is not
the reality is that it is not the
Constitution that has failed us is us
that has failed the Constitution
Frederick Douglass a man who's born a
slave said interpreted as it ought to be
the Constitution is a glorious Liberty
document
but Frederick Douglass is not in there
he goes on to give us a blueprint for
the path to Liberty I hope that every
American citizen has the right to form
an opinion of the Constitution and to
propagate that opinion and to use all
honorable means to make his opinion the
prevailing one without this right the
liberty of an American citizen would be
as insecure as that of a Frenchman
leaving the protection of her Liberty to
a document is leaving is subject to the
interpretation of the day our individual
freedom is not well protected by any
piece of paper but it is protected by
spreading our message of Liberty
it is not enough
to Simply spread it to our neighbors our
cities our States it must be spread as
widely as possible the serious defense
of our Liberty is not found in a commune
or even in a nation but in the hearts
and minds of our fellow man
there are those who claim that true
liberalism has failed in this mission to
convince others but we live in a world
entirely entirely transformed
by Liberty
poverty War famine and disease went from
being the norm to the abnorm who live in
a time where we can have these
discussions about National breakup in
large part because of the freedom and
peace and prosperity that liberalism
created
over only a hundred years ago it would
have been far too dangerous the world to
even consider breaking into smaller
Nations
liberalism the certainly in in perfect
form is the standard in the West
and as an economic and as economic
Liberty increases Prosperity throughout
the world
other Liberties will follow
the path towards a true Improvement in
human Affairs does not lie in fiddling
with the dials of a nation's makeup it
lies in convincing the world to let
everyone pursue their own interests as
long as they don't harm anyone else
thank you
[Applause]
uh Jane uh please open uh the final vote
yes no or undecided on the resolution I
have in my hand the soul form Tootsie
Roll that goes to the winner who moves
the vote in his favor uh the breakup of
the United States into different regions
is a workable option likely to bring a
marked improvement in human Affairs all
right I want to announce uh and and hope
you can come to our next debate here at
the sheen Center that will be Thursday
March 30th Manhattan Institute senior
fellow Jason Riley will defend the
resolution upward Mobility for black
Americans lives in rejecting the
policies of progressive government while
making the most of the opportunities
offered by American society against NYU
Professor nikhil Singh again that will
be Thursday March 30th tickets are on
sale for that debate I also of course
want to invite you to the reception
afterwards I know that Frank has to take
off he's got to teach a school teach
class in the morning but Gerald will be
there all of you will be there follow us
to 55 great Jones Street whether or not
you bought a ticket food and drink and
lots of interaction awaits you at our
place afterwards well on Thursday April
20th University of California North
South Carolina professor of History
Woody Holton will defend the resolution
the New York Times book The 1619 project
and the Hulu video Hulu video series
based on it are important contributions
to our understanding of slavery and the
role of African Americans in American
history against aie our senior fellow
Phil Magnus that's the debate on the 16
19 project Monday May 22nd Northwestern
University professor of Law and
philosophy Andrew koppelman will defend
the resolution
libertarianism has been thoroughly
corrupted by delusion greed and disdain
for the weak
taking the negative will be me
come on done
[Applause]
in uh in June well uh let's see how I do
uh
in uh June uh we are taking our show on
the road we're going back to porcupine
Fest in New Hampshire that state that
might secede on the Free State of New
Hampshire as the Libertarians like to
call it because they're trying to take
over the state uh pork fest and
Lancaster New Hampshire uh is an event
that we will be attending now for the
third time uh I'll be hosting one of the
debates and also actually participating
one of the debates a Machinery Freedom
author David Friedman will defend the
resolution the right way to persuade
people of libertarianism is by showing
them that its outcomes are superior by
their standards without any resort to
the flawed non-aggression principle
again taking the negative against David
will be me I hope you can join us for
pork fest up in New Hampshire uh yeah
it's a wonderful event they're great
accommodations and it goes on for three
or four days that's uh in June uh in
late June uh also uh we have further
events uh Tuesday July 25th Cato
Institute senior fellow Alex narasta
will defend the resolution the U.S
should have free immigration except for
those who pose a security threat or have
a serious contagious disease against
Manhattan contrarian blogger Francis
mentioned August is to be announced we
haven't done an August yet but we do
have a September debate lined up as well
September 18th all of these uh uh
debates are listed on our website and
tickets are on sale and that will be
there September 18th will be a debate
about animal capitalism Jane I think you
are finding that please come I think
Jane has gotten the final vote for us to
announce about who gets the Tootsie Roll
drumroll please
now
the yes votes began with 35 percent but
lost 11 points to 23 points uh so that's
the number to do worse than the no vote
gained 25 points so the Tootsie Roll
Goes to Jail congratulations Gerald
thank you